andrew is with us Andrews in New York hi
Andrew how are you
every day when I talk to you you too sir
what's up okay financially but I want to
try to do better with the right
direction so I'm 39 I have a 283 K
mortgage and 140 K instant death I don't
have a 403 B or college savings as of
yet and we'd love to increase our
emergency for my wife and I that's what
the student that my wife has evaded her
70 K and half is mine my half is being
paid with public service loan
forgiveness and hers is not budget wise
I could pay over her minimum by maybe 50
bucks I want to try to attack it
together as your household income 67k I
am the sole provider good lord
my wife is amazing at everything else
but I am being big arena and so she paid
seventy thousand dollars to get a degree
in doesn't use it for now I mean we have
a two year old and another one on the
way
what is her degree in done great job
counseling mental health counseling did
she get licensed she'd get her master's
she did get her her master she did not
get licensed but it's just the case of
she gave birth and I wasn't accused of
being lazy I'm just saying you guys have
you guys have a financial crisis on your
hands because your income to your debt
ratio is absolutely scaring the crud out
of me dude y'all got to be terrified you
have a little shovel and you are
standing Nick deep in a big hole okay
scaring me for you I would be scared so
if I want to do something to increase
your household income because we've got
to get rid of these student loans
because the student loan public student
loan forgiveness program you talk about
the 10-year program I am talking about
the program and I'm already three years
into it never not read that it doesn't
exist what do you mean
35,000 people have made application 93
received the forgiveness the government
is not honoring it okay it's not a good
get out of debt plan they lied to you
okay
and I mean go go google it go Google and
see what's happening with it there's
almost none of the applications are
going through after people waited 10
years and did the public service and so
on it's it's been up it's been a bad
deal um so yeah what I would say is you
have 140,000 dollars of student loan
debt and we've got to come up with a
plan other than sixty seven thousand
dollars to get you out of that and that
involves what do you do for a living I
work in social services okay can you
pick up side case work currently
actively looking for site anything
really sure if you can get casework
it'll be paid be your best pay as side
case work and and then your wife needs
to go ahead and get licensed even though
she's a full-time mom and I appreciate
and I want her to I want to honor her
decision to do that but she needs to go
ahead and get her license so that she
can do side counseling as well some
evenings and weekends and stuff when
you're around with the kiddos so that
she can pick up because a good marriage
counts therapist as an example make a
hundred hundred a half an hour and you
guys need the money so she need an her
side gig she's got a she's got a
master's going and get the license and
let's get the counseling business
started it doesn't have to be super
fancy it didn't have to be a big deal
but you can she can had some real
substantial dollars without sacrificing
her too much of her time with her
children with your children and I'm not
asking her to go crazy here but I mean
20 hours a week would go a long way at a
hundred bucks an hour go a long way in
this situation it would increase your
income considerably and if you can pick
up casework on the side as well we've
got to begin to address these student
loans because they're not going away sir
I wish they were going away but they're
not going away
and the only way they're going to go
is when you guys get after them and you
don't have a lot of margin and a 67
thousand dollar budget to to pay tens of
thousands of dollars $50 is you're gonna
be a hundred years getting out fifty
dollars you need five thousand dollars a
month going towards this and that's
going to involve your all changing your
income structure to be able to do that
I'm so sorry I wish you weren't there
I feel scared for you